bonsoir nadège alors que peut-on retenir
de cette prise de parole écoutée
stéphanie olivier ferrand très inquiet
de la poussée des différents variant
britannique sud africain et brésilien
des variants que le ministre de la santé
estime dangereux et plus contagieux
alors en ce qui concerne le variant
britannique
il a été repéré dans 20 à 25% des cas de
contamination au quotidien au co vide
le vaccin serait très efficace dit-il un
olivier v rencontre
ce variant en revanche le doute
persistant sur les variants sud africain
et brésilien qui pour leur part ont été
repérés dans 4 à 5 % des cas de
contamination des variants qui
augmenterait les risques de réinfection
chez les patients déjà contaminé aux
copies de 19
olivier ferrand c'est aussi lors de
cette conférence de presse dit satisfait
de la stratégie française de lutte
contre la propagation du virus stratégie
en opposition avec celle de nos voisins
européens notamment au sujet du
confinement
nos voisins ont confiné parce qu'il
n'avait plus le choix
l'allemagne et l'angleterre ont connu
des journées avec plus de 1500 morts par
jour et donc il n'avait pas d'autre
alternative que celle d'un confinement
généralisée parce qu'il risque et une
saturation de leurs hôpitaux
c'est le cas aussi aux pays bas en
irlande en autriche et dans de nombreux
pays et nadège olivier ferrand qui s'est
toutefois inquiétée de la situation en
moselle où les quatre contamination sont
en hausse
absolument dans ce territoire du grand
est et près de 300 cas de contamination
aux variants brésilien et sud africains
ont été diagnostiqués au cours des
quatre derniers jours la situation
tellement inquiétante que le ministre de
la santé a décidé de se déplacer demain
en moselle la situation est un peu
différente dans un département du
territoire c'est la moselle c'est une
situation plus inquiétante
nous avons identifié dans ce département
plus de 300 cas de mutation évocatrice
des variants sud africain et brésilien
ces quatre derniers jours je me rendrai
demain en moselle pour évaluer sur place
la situation et échanger avec les élus
du territoire
j mènerait une concertation afin
d'anticiper les réponses qu'il nous
faudra trouver collectivement et un peu
plus tôt dans la journée olivier verront
s'est rendu dans une école du xiiie
arrondissement de paris avec jean castex
le premier ministre à nadège
et le butin de cette visite dans cette
école c'est dû déployer une nouvelle
arme contre la propagation du coc u19 le
test salivaire une technique moins
douloureuse que le prélèvement nasal
puisqu'il consiste un prélèvement dans
la bouche ou un prélèvement parts rachat
à la rentrée des vacances d'hiver
le gouvernement espère ainsi que 200 à
300 milles et tests salivaires seront
effectués et chaque semaine dans les
écoles ces tests salivaires évidemment
chacun a connu le test naso pharyngé et
ses inconvénients
le test salivaire évidemment beaucoup
plus facile d'accès il permet là aussi
d'avoir des résultats dans des délais
rapides 24 heures puisque c'est la
technique pcr pour être extrêmement
précis et donc nous avons décidé de le
déployer d'abord on le comprend guère en
direction des enfants dans les écoles
dans les collèges dans les lycées parce
qu'évidemment c'est un public qui est
plus fragile et qui est parfois plus
réticents aux tests naso pharyngé et aux
désagréments qu'il peut provoquer c'est
dans une école parisienne auquel n'a pas
participé à laquelle n'a pas participé
jean michel blanc car le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a été retenu à
l'assemblée nationale où les débats sur
le projet de loi séparatisme se sont
poursuivies ce jeudi encore merci
n'avait jamais razak en direct de
avenue de ségur